Oh,
vous avez fermé plus de villes que l'
équipe derrière vous à trois chiffres, comment faites-
vous ? J'ai grandi dans une grande
communauté
agricole.  était juste brisé,
nous vendons le seul moyen de
revenir Je suis heureux d'annoncer que
nous apporterons du gaz naturel à McKinley Je
ne peux pas croire que c'est juste à l'extérieur de la
ville, on dirait le Kentucky, à deux heures de
toute ville, on dirait le Kentucky  êtes-
vous le propriétaire de cet endroit ouais eh bien
comment se fait-il que vous fassiez tout le travail que vous
signez ce bail cela nous donne le droit de
forer sur votre terrain
tout cet argent là-bas c'est la
vérité en fait il n'y a aucune raison pour que votre
ville ne le soit pas  avoir un lycée à la pointe de la technologie de
quel genre d'argent
parlez-vous vous pourriez être millionnaire
mais ce serait plus difficile c'est trop facile de faire des
recherches pour dire quoi que ce soit sur une
présence environnementale vous savez je suppose
40 marketing marié  g
trente-huit strip-teaseuse / serveuse mais
née pour être chanteuse ouais non non je
parlais de moi
salut tout le monde je suis là parce que ma ferme est
partie la terre vient de brunir est morte
c'est arrivé à l'un de nous ça peut arriver
à tous  d'entre nous,
la ville va mettre aux voix dans
trois semaines ce qui s'est passé tu
étais censé entrer maintenant tout
sur ta compagnie sais ce que tu fais tu
penses que le javelot est X pour te battre ouais hé
là elle
est prête à partir  ouais
cette ville cette lumière est en train de mourir
vous la voyez tous venir et vous ne vous écartez
pas du chemin nous ne nous battons pas
pour la terre Steve nous nous battons pour les gens
vous n'obtiendrez jamais ce que vous êtes
venu prendre ici  moi, comment sont-ils comme
le fait que tu essaies ici tu es
un homme bon Steve ils souhaitent juste que
tu ne fasses pas ça
pour une entreprise de neuf milliards de dollars sais-tu
ce que nous sommes capables de faire toi
toi